thank you so much professor Alexander
it's such an
to be here and to even see you after all
these years to even be on the same stage
the poet still means a lot to a
journalist it's still an out-of-body
experience to be standing here before
you today after having completed this
book I have been on a journey of my own
just to report and to write this book
this book is 15 years of of love and
obsession and passion and dedication and
absorption into another era it's 15
years so that if this were human being
it would be in high school and dating
which gives you a sense of what it took
to write this book I come to you as a
journalist who has made the transition
of the journey herself from daily
journalism newspaper journalism at the I
would argue and say always the best
newspaper in the country if not the
world and devoted myself to
understanding what I believe to be the
biggest underreported story of the 20th
century I'm glad that I didn't know it
was going to take 15 years because I
don't think I would have finished it I
don't think I would have embarked upon
it had I known but I'm glad that I
didn't know because it allowed me to to
start this and to complete it now I
decided to devote myself for my first
book to something gargantuan
something that lasted throughout most of
the 20th century involved six million
people changed altered forever the
demographics the culture the politics of
our country so I just thought I'd start
with something small you know go from
small with smaller stories or run a
newspaper in a day to something it would
take 15 years this story is a universal
story of longing and determination which
I was can
Vince from the very beginning could have
meaning for people far beyond the reach
of the stories itself themselves these
people who left had the immigrant heart
they had the same longing and
determination for something better as
anyone who ever crossed the Atlantic in
steerage across the Pacific Ocean and
hopes for something better across the
Rio Grande to get to this country and in
fact it's the story if you think of it
of almost every American because who
among us would even be here had there
not been someone in our backgrounds from
someplace far away who had the courage
the will the determination and the grit
to leave the only place that they'd ever
known for a place that they'd never seen
in hopes that life might be better no
guarantees whatsoever and we all in some
ways though our existence to that how
many of us have I've know if so many
people who have say an Irish
great-grandmother who met an Italian
great-grandfather on the Lower East Side
of Manhattan or on the southwest side of
Chicago or perhaps in Boston and they
never would have met they came here and
created whole new lineages and we in
fact Oh a debt our very existence in
fact to someone who did that otherwise
we wouldn't be here that is truly the
American story and that's what happened
within the own borders of our of our own
country now these six million people who
left this great migration began during
World War one and did not end until 1970
when the essential conditions that had
led to the - this migration were finally
resolved in the south I consider this to
be what I call the overground railroad
because in some ways they were
responding to and acting upon the unmet
promises of the Emancipation
Proclamation in other words the
Emancipation Proclamation did not live
up to its name and it took these people
to actually make it become real to free
themselves these were in my view
defections from a caste
these people were seeking political
asylum as any group of people might
think political asylum in this country
except they were citizens already and
that makes it all the more poignant to
me all the more tragic in some ways and
all the more daring in its own way and
that is in fact the reason why it went
underreported for so long because people
didn't take notice of people who were
migrating within their own borders there
was there was no Ellis Island to through
which the people had to be processed
they if they could manage to get out
they were they were free to leave the
question was how they were gonna get out
now I focus so much on trying to
understand what was the world that they
were leaving what would propel six
million people to leave the land of
their forefathers for a place that
they'd never seen in search of what
Richard Wright calls the warmth of other
Suns they in fact we're not leaving for
a warmer Thunder they were leaving for
Suns as we know so well just looking
outside today is clearly not any warmer
than those that they were leaving but
symbolically they were my mother
actually was always a believer in this
title so the book was a nameless orphan
child for a very long time and I while I
was working on it and settled on this
title for reasons I could talk about a
little bit later and she said to me she
was a part of this great migration she
said to me yes we we had to leave
because our son was cold our son was
cold
now they were living under an artificial
hierarchy a caste system which as with
the it's it's related word caste as one
would put on a broken bone is in some
ways a stricter it holds one fast in a
certain place and that's exactly what
this caste system did people were
assigned to a certain caste upon birth
based upon lineage and what they look
like such that there was no opportunity
at
a point for there to be almost any
interaction between the races save for
the actual mechanics of work that was
the only way that they could be that
there could be any interaction between
the two so that in Birmingham it was
actually against the law
for a black person and a white person to
play checkers together one has to
imagine how someone came up with that as
a law someone must have seen a black
person and a white person playing
checkers in some courthouse square in
Birmingham and perhaps the two were
having too good a time maybe they were
laughing joking I'm between the two of
them and someone must have seen it and
said that the entire foundation of the
American South is imperiled and we must
end this now so someone had to go and
write this out as a law so that this
would not happen anymore
this would have heard everyone would
have heard the black person who wanted
to play and the white person who might
have really quite enjoyed playing
checkers with their friend but this was
an indication of just how far the
southern caste system was going to go to
maintain this system which was required
to ensure that there would be an
oversupply of ready and willing cheap
labour to work the cotton to work the
cotton fields to work the tobacco fields
to raise the the rice the sugar cane and
all the other things that the southern
caste system had relied upon in order to
make the economy work throughout the
south in courtrooms there was a black
Bible and a white Bible to swear to tell
the truth on I could asked about that
when I mention it they say well was it a
different kind of Bible like the King
James Version for one an American
Standard for another it turns out that
it was the exact same Bible that wasn't
the point the point was that they could
not touch the same sacred text and I
found out about this law almost by
accident I was looking for something
else and I came
a client across an article in a North
North Carolina newspaper and the North
Carolina newspaper was commenting on the
fact that this was a law but not out of
alarm or shame or embarrassment or even
really announcing that there was a law
they the the story came about because
the need for a second Bible had created
a disruption in the courthouse in the
courtroom that day they had to suspend
the trial in order to find a Bible
because they could not find the black
Bible so they had to look for the black
Bible and that meant that the bailiff
and all the court officers had to go
from courtroom to courtroom search that
courtroom in order to find the Bible for
the black witness that had just taken
the stand and so this is an indication
of just how normal it was viewed it was
considered just an ordinary thing and
the judge upon ordering the bailiff to
find the black Bible said well this is
the court this is a court of law
and this is the law of the state and
therefore we must abide by that so we
must find this black Bible and they did
now when I talk about the the Jim Crow
which is what is the the term that weed
is often used to describe what I call a
caste system I often looked I was look I
spend a lot of time looking for all of
the possible ways that were devised to
keep these races these different levels
of the caste separate there are no
references in the book to water
fountains or restrooms because we know
that already so there are no references
to that I was looking for any other
possible example to make real for the
reader what it was like to be in that
circumstance so that a person might have
to would be forced I would hope to think
what would I do if I were in that
situation what would I do what I stay or
what I leave so one of the examples that
I find in talking about this book I find
that one example seems to get to people
quite a bit and I'd like to see if
people would be willing to raise their
hand if they have ever passed someone
on the road he was driving too slowly
anyone ever passed someone why would you
do that
this is laughter because it's so obvious
well it turns out that under the caste
system an african-american motorist was
not permitted to pass a white motorist
on the road no matter how slowly that
person was driving no matter how many
times and we all have been through this
the person stopped because they thought
that was the turn but no it was not the
turn maybe it's the next to turn and
then the next turn and there was nothing
that that person could do and as I have
talked with with younger people about it
with the high school students even about
the reality of this caste system and I
tell them about this they will often say
well I would have hopped
someone even said I would bump them and
I said no you would not because one of
the one of the realities of this caste
system is that because it was so
artificial was an artificial hierarchy
that had been created in order to
maintain an economic system that really
truly was was in peril to begin with and
unsustainable to begin with that it had
to be brutally enforced it was enforced
with such sent a level of terror and
violence that every four days every four
days somewhere in the South an
african-american was lynched over all
kinds of things and not always the
things that traditionally have been
viewed as the precipitating events that
would lead to lynching such as the
accusation of the rape of a white woman
that was one of the many reasons that a
person could be lynched but I came
across so many other examples one man
was lynched for having stolen been
accused of having stolen 75 cents for 75
cents
he was dope he was lynched others were
lynched because they had been accused of
stealing a hog others were lynched for a
very common cause of lynching was the
accusation of having been have having
acted like a white person whatever that
means that means for whatever reason
they had done something they had not
stepped off the sidewalk they had not
stopped for the white mode of motorists
they had looked straight into the eyes
of a white person and called them by
their first name they had made some
breach of southern protocol that
warranted action that would then be put
all the other people in that same caste
on notice that this was not acceptable
behavior so for many many reasons these
people many purported reasons these
people were were we're living under
extreme terror that is almost hard to
believe it doesn't even sound like the
United States of America it sounds like
the Soviet Union but during the Cold War
and yet this was within our own country
so that meant that for much of the 20th
century and particularly in the
of the 20th century until the 1960s
every african-american family in the
South had a decision to make they had to
think about whether they were one of
today or whether they want to go and I
wanted to read you a passage a very
short one it was an anonymous quote
anonymous because it was too dangerous
for this woman to let her name be known
as she was expressing the sense of fear
and and agitation among the people to
try to figure out what to do she wrote
in our homes in our churches wherever
two or three are gathered there is a
discussion of what is best to do must we
remain in the south or go elsewhere
where can we go to find that security
which other people feel is it best to go
in great numbers or only in several
families these and many other things are
discussed over and over this is a woman
in Alabama of 1902 in the on the cusp of
the great migration so it turned out
that the people had wanted to go all
along but because there had been no
opening for them to leave that actually
from the time from emancipation until
the beginning of the great migration
there actually were very few people who
actually made it out we know about the
Underground Railroad that occurred
during slavery but afterward you would
think that things were open and they
were putative Lee free they would have
left but it turns out that they needed
to they needed a signal that there were
options someplace else and that signal
came during World War one during World
War one the North had a problem the
North had a great need for labor because
the emigration from Europe came to a
virtual halt because Europe was at war
and with Europe at war that the
immigrants the European immigrants who
were already here we often call back
home to help with the war effort and
that meant that the northern factories
the foundries the steel mills the
slaughterhouses the railroads all needed
labor at a time when there was a great
urgency because the world was at war and
yet they didn't have war
to fill those slots and so they began to
look around and to figure out where can
we go to find the labor that we need and
they went to the cheapest labor in the
country the cheapest labor in the land
and that would have been African
Americans in the South because many
African Americans in the South many of
them were sharecroppers or farmers and
they were working merely for the right
to live on the land they were farming
and that meant that they were readily
and quite anxious to leave if there were
a signal that there were options
recruiters from the north came to the
south to began looking for labor and
found it found it there and that is how
the great migration began however once
that began the South went into a deep
panic they could see that there were
going to be they were this was a great
threat to the economic system and the
social and cultural system and life of
those in the South would come to depend
upon an oversupply of cheap labor to do
whatever was needed to serve the needs
of the highest caste and so this is what
the make and Telegraph had to say at
this moment everybody seems to be asleep
about what is going on right under our
noses that is everybody but those
farmers who have wakened up on mornings
recently to find every Negro over 21 on
his place gone to Cleveland to
Pittsburgh to Chicago to Indianapolis
and while our very solvency are very
solvency not people not human beings but
our very solvency is being sucked out
beneath us we go about our affairs as
usual this is September 1916 when it
began to hit the south when it became
clear that these people were leaving
they were leaving because they now have
the option to do so which they had not
had before and so what this meant was
the South had to go to great lengths to
see what it could do or what it thought
it could do to keep the people from
leaving so what did they do they began
to arrest people from the railroad
platforms when there were large numbers
of black people with tickets leading
heading north they would board the
trains and arrest them from this
and accused them of or charge them with
vagrancy or not of not working which of
course they were not working at the
moment cuz they were leaving they would
when there were too many people for them
to arrest they would wave the train on
through so for the train would not stop
and so with the people the people who
had saved up all those months or perhaps
even over a year for that train ticket
to go had could see the train that the
train that they had hoped would lead
them to freedom passing right by them
and there was nothing they could do
about it at that time they began to find
other ways to get out instead they would
go to nearby nearby towns they would go
south in order to go north they would
leave in the middle of the night and
pack their things and not tell anyone
they became to be aware that if they
were seen in large numbers attempting to
lead that that could imperil their
efforts to get out and so they found
other ways to get around it and in fact
the but the preeminent sociologists of
the day who did much of the work on
covering the great migration dr. Charles
Johnson I became a president of Fisk
University he wrote that actually these
efforts by the south to keep the people
from leaving only fed the urge to leave
because it was a reminder that this
place was not a place that was going to
get better for them or that would would
make life tenable for them now there was
a great urgency in quest that they had
in the South some people wondered
whether they should treat the people
better and there was an example of one
one planter who made the ultimate
sacrifice
he decided that what I'm doing is not
working so what I shall do is I think I
will put away my whip and gun and maybe
they will stay now and he made that
clear to the people but the people had
decided at that point that they were
going to go and so then we had this
migration on I want to say a little bit
about how I and why I decided to spend
so much of my time working on this I
myself am a product of this great
migration
and it has touched me so many times as
I've worked on this book that I would
not even have existed and perhaps the
majority of African Americans would not
even have existed had there been no
great migration simply wouldn't have
existed which is also the case for most
Americans if you're descended from two
streams of migration one from from say
China and another from Ireland and you
simply wouldn't have existed they would
never have met had had these two streams
not come together in this continent and
it's the same is the case for most
African Americans my mother migrated
from Rome Georgia to Washington DC my
father from Petersburg Virginia to
Washington DC after after he had been a
Tuskegee Airmen and they would never
have met had they not been part of great
migration but growing up no one talked
about it as a great migration no one
very rarely would you even hear the term
used no one said things like well
remember when the great migration began
or remember when all those people came
up in the great migration or remember
how during the great migration people
did this or did that people don't talk
about it people in fact did not talk
about what they had experienced people
in fact did not talk about the south
it's almost as if we had just landed
from another planet and just were there
there was no backstory there was nothing
that preceded that in fact many of them
when they left because they were leaving
such such heartache and and terror in
fact for some of them that they often
changed their names they changed their
accents they became northern they turned
their backs on all that they had known
and became as northern and or American
as they could imagine themselves to be
and so I grew up in a world in which I
was surrounded by people from North
Carolina and South Carolina which I
understand and know is the one of the
great tributaries to Newhaven
example that in some ways much of
Connecticut is sort of North Carolina
South Carolina north and and I grew up
in that same that same environment but
you know he hearing the the language the
music partaking of the food and the
folkways the spiritual values the folk
wisdom that comes from that rural rural
southern culture a small-town culture
that is what I grew up with but no one
ever described it as anything beyond
just I left and so I wanted to
understand that better and that's the
reason why I set out to tell this story
with great urgency when I began it
because the people this migration began
in 1916 and that means that these people
were leaving us rapidly I went about it
with great urgency knowing that the
stories were this in order to get the
story I had to act fast because the
stories were not going to be there
forever these people were not going to
be with us forever and I needed to get
to them very quickly before before was
too late so I set out on a course in
which I went out and interviewed people
in all these different senior centers
and AARP meetings and meetings of
retired postal workers and quilting
clubs and churches in in Brooklyn where
everybody was from South Carolina and
Catholic churches in Louisiana I'm sorry
in Los Angeles where everyone is from
Louisiana and so all of these all of
these in all of these places I went
looking for people who might be able to
share their stories and when I would go
in it turned out that everywhere you
went you were running into these
beautiful streams that showed the the
the predictability and the kind of
comforting movements of people that
could be predicted so precisely that if
you go to Los Angeles you could be
pretty much assured that many of the
people you run into her from Texas or
Louisiana that is just the way this
migration unfolded the migration
unfolded in three separate streams three
major streams with tributaries along the
way one was the East Coast stream where
we're pretty much at the end of that
stream people really wanted to get a
when they came up to Connecticut I think
this stream is the one that took people
from Florida the Carolinas Georgia and
Virginia to Washington DC the first stop
some people said this is far enough for
me and then up to Philadelphia New York
Connecticut Boston and that was this
East Coast dream that was a stream that
my family was a part of and to give you
an example of how beautifully
predictable it is when I went to these
other places to do the reporting and
this reporting took off took almost two
years just to settle on these three
people when I would go to California I
would run into people from a different
stream and I almost had to prove myself
because the question was where are your
people from the expectation was if I'm
in California then clearly you from
Texas of Louisiana which I was not and
the food was different they were eating
ox tails and red beans and rice my
mother wasn't didn't make that when I
was growing up when I was in Chicago
talking to doing the research on this
they ate different food suddenly I was
exposed to something called hog head
cheese how many of you heard of that and
I was I didn't know what it was and it
was a delicacy which was offered on on a
bus trip to one of the floating casinos
in Iowa and the seniors there were so
excited because someone had the good
stuff direct from the source in
Mississippi and they were passing it
around and I had to find a way to let
them know that I was just gonna pass on
that and I would get it the next time I
didn't know what it was I literally
don't know what it was my mother had
made that and it's true that many people
force took everything and actually did
not make anything from the old country
my mother actually did but ours was a
different thing was more scrapple and
grits and collard greens a turnip greens
which she preferred but in any case I
found that there were cultural
differences it actually created some
challenges and they've been just doing
the work so when I was in California I
had to prove myself many times over had
to learn the names the pronunciations of
the small towns in Louisiana which
weren't not just rolling off the tongue
for me given what I was exposed to and
where I was from same goes for
for Mississippi where had to learn the
language and the and the pronunciations
almost as if you're talking about
different country but when I got to New
York which was my focus for this for the
for this migration stream for the
protagonist for my book I actually ran
into people who knew my father from
Petersburg Virginia that is how
beautifully predictable this migration
is in the same way that if you go to
Minnesota you went to a lot of people
from Scandinavia and it's the same thing
with this migration I just find that to
be one of the comforting things about
human human behavior is that we're
actually quite predictable and we like
to do things in an orderly fashion and
this was a fairly this is not a
haphazard unfurling of lost souls this
was a very orderly transfer of a good
portion of the black population of an
entire population along the bus routes
and the railroad lines that took them
out the most direct routes out of
wherever they happen to be and that is
the reason why when I went to these
different places I was running in to
certain people from certain places and
very few people very little
cross-pollination when it came to this
which is quite comforting in and of
itself
now that means then that the majority of
african-americans that you meet in the
north and west are descended from this
great migration the majority this
migration began 90% of all
african-americans 90% we're living in
the south all concentrated in this one
region of the country by the end of this
great migration nearly half of living
all in all parts North Midwest and west
from Washington to this great arc north
to to Connecticut in Boston New England
over to Cleveland and Detroit in Chicago
and all the way over to the west coast
they were everywhere but the south and
that caused a total redistribution of an
entire people which had the effect of
putting pressure on the south in ways
that it had not anticipated pressure on
the north that could not have been
anticipated and this unfolding of this
migration which at every point along the
way every key point
the end of World War one at the end of
World War two people were saying it's
over the people are not gonna come
anymore clearly there's no reason for
them to come but no one told the people
that make kept coming because you know
human behavior is not always so
controllable as that no one told them
that it was over so they kept coming
this migration has changed American
culture in ways that we are still trying
to understand to give you a few examples
of the ways that it affected our culture
one example is the effect on the
politics of our country and I mean the
laws and politics and the ultimate end
of the caste system is as it had been
known in the south this end of the caste
system would have ended eventually it
would have ended eventually but this
great migration helped to accelerate it
the people at the time of the great
migration began we're not in a position
to have exerted their will as even
though they might have wanted to they
were not in a position even to honk at
someone who was driving slowly in front
of them much less tell them you will let
us vote you will let us walk into the
front door of the courthouse they were
not in a position to do that the time
was not right for it and the
demographics of the south meant that
economically speaking there were too
many african-americans too much too many
of the low of the cheap labor all
concentrated an oversupply which meant
that they had there that the value of
that labor had been quite low and to
increase the value of that labor meant
there needed to be less of that labor in
the south and these people without a
leader this is a leaderless revolution
which is perhaps to me the most
inspiring part of this entire migration
and the most inspiring thing about any
immigrant experience is that no one
sounds the hour or the day as to when it
shall begin
no one said on this day we shall all go
no leader said that it is best for us to
leave because economically we will have
will have more power if we and more
influence and greater value if we are
someplace
the people within their hearts took an
accounting of their circumstance and
said it would be better for us to leave
these were individual decisions when you
talk with them they don't speak of
themselves as being a part of the great
migration when I would go to these
senior centers and talk with them if I
were to say to them how many of you were
a part of the great migration not a
single hand would go up if I asked them
how many of you left Louisiana or Texas
for California between the years of 1960
to 1970 every hand would go up because
they didn't view themselves as part of
this great migration they were making
decisions that were particular to them
and their circumstances at that time at
that place and they decided that they
could not take this caste system one day
longer and they made this decision so
this is a leaderless revolution and that
revolution slowly person by person one
by one one put extreme pressure on the
South to change and it did it had effect
on the people who stayed there were
people who stayed and they needed to
stay because it needed to be someone to
be there to fight the ultimate battle
which we call the civil rights movement
of the 1960s there needed to be people
there to brave those sheriffs hoses and
those dogs and to March those marches
but there also needed to people be
people outside of it the effect of the
people on the outside was tremendous in
the same way that from our perch here in
the United States we can have tremendous
influence on other parts of the world
where there are atrocities or human
rights abuses because we have the means
to do that we can be more watchful we
can make contributions financially we
can provide a political lever for those
people in other places and the exact
same thing happened north and south with
this great migration having so many
people in the North that the people in
the south could now point to and say if
things get difficult I can go to a
cousin in Cleveland that makes a big
difference as you're going out and
braving those sheriff's hoses they also
were they were exposed to the options
and to what life could be like when you
were free Martin Luther King himself had
gone to Boston University and gotten his
doctorate there and it was in Boston
that he met his wife Coretta Scott King
that had a tremendous impact on his
ability to then go return to the south
and fight the fact the final battle for
freedom ultimately for his people for
african-americans but it was a exposure
to the north being able to get on a
train and I have to sit in the back
being able to to actually shake the hand
of a person of a different race which
was not permitted in the in the South
believed in I was another one of the
strictures one of the protocols it was
not permitted such that a historian said
that in the South very very few people
of one race or the other had ever shaken
the hand of someone of another race
because I was not permitted so the the
existence of large numbers of
african-americans in the north and west
did several things it provided an a
political psychological emotional and
political lever that could be used by
those in the south it exposed those in
the south to the freedoms that could be
experienced by people who look just like
them in a different place that was was
always looming there it also meant that
there were people in the North who had
means just by going to the north while
that might not have been their initial
their primary concern at the time they
were leaving some people leaving just
merely to save - in order to avoid being
killed but by being in the north they
were automatically gonna be making more
money than the people in the south and
they were sending money back home just
like every immigrant group does they
were sending money back much more often
that they could eat then they could even
afford and they were sending money back
to the mothers and the fathers that
needed their help and to support this
this nascent
civil rights movement that ultimately
was going to need a lot of support in
order to succeed so all of these things
were working north and south to help
change the south helped to affect change
in the north even and ultimately to open
the way for all other kinds of freedom
movements
now can take for granted freedom from
women freedom for other immigrant groups
freedom for even the disabled all of
these things that grew out of the
initial efforts that occurred during the
early there in the mid-1960s that were
the catalyst for other kind of types of
change and which started because the
people the lowest caste people in the
south sent a signal to the north and the
south that they had options and they
were willing to take them now that's one
part of the effect but the effect that I
think I like to talk about the most is
the effect that is really the perhaps
the the major way of gauging the effect
of any immigration and that is the
children who are in some ways the the
great legacy of any any great movement
of people what is it that what is it
that the people were leaving when they
left the sovereign what was on their
hearts and on their minds when they were
leaving for almost any immigrant it is
almost too late for them truly to
benefit from the migration that they're
about to embark on whatever limits on
education they had there was not much it
was going to change that once they were
30 years old and packing up their their
Pontiac and heading north or boarding
the train with their young children and
heading north or leaving the leaving
Ireland or Poland or what war or Italy
for this for the new world their lives
had already been fairly well established
whatever lacking and nutrition made
experience they had already experienced
but that wasn't the case for the
children the children might have it
better and any emigration involves hope
that life will be better for the
children and that was what that is where
you can see the true impact of this
great migration these children of the
great migration had the opportunity to
do things that their parents could only
have dreamt of some of the people who
are part of this great migration include
Toni Morrison for example Toni Morrison
her parents migrated from Alabama to
Ohio where she got the opportunity
which her parents never would have had
never had and what she would not have
had had they stayed which is merely to
walk into a library and to borrow to
take out a library book she would not
have been able to do that in Alabama
during the time that she would have been
growing up and that's kind of an
important thing to be able to do if
you're gonna be a Nobel laureate you
know you need to be able to read a book
to get access to a book and she would
not have been able to do that so many
other writers in fact much of the
african-american literature of the 20th
century is essentially about the great
migration which is one of the things
that I found someone's firing about this
I mean much of the poetry were speaking
of Gwendolyn Brooks for example when we
speak of Toni Morrison's work herself a
Richard writer almost everything he
wrote was about the great migration it
was about reconciling his experience in
the south and his search for freedom
somewhere outside of the south and
feeling bound by that somehow invisible
man even is about the great migration on
some level and about the the the ship
from the Southern College to life in New
York and feeling invisible as a result
of that migration in theatre Lorraine
Hansberry and August Wilson there were
all the schools of entire cycle is
essentially about the great migration
the uprooting of people from the south
to Pittsburgh and he used that as at the
centerpiece to understand what had this
done to an entire people to be uprooted
from a place that they had not really
wanted to leave and had been forced to
leave and that's just in literature in
art romare bearden and jacob lawrence
devoted all most of their energy to
cataloging into - to describing and to
somehow trying to interpret and make
real and there are the the pain and the
the heartache and the joys even that
came from this great migration they are
symbols of the very thing that we're
talking about this means that much of
twentieth-century art as and create
creativity as we know it was all born
out of this great migration when it
comes to music music simply would not be
is where there nope no great migration
in fact I would argue that the American
ear has been reshaped by the transfer of
southern folk music to the north through
this great migration and and the
marriage of both southern music to to
the to the north and the mout metabolize
differently here and got exposure in
ways that it would not have been exposed
otherwise for example we all know about
the blues Muddy Waters and BB King all
were migrants themselves coming to the
north from the Mississippi Delta with
their 12 string guitars and the music's
and that music in their head but I like
to think about other things too which
simply would not have existed Motown for
example simply wouldn't have existed
without the great migration it
absolutely would not have existed and
that's because Berry Gordy the founder
of of Motown his parents migrated from
Georgia and they migrated from Georgia
to Detroit where once he grew up he
decided and want to go into music he did
not have necessarily great singing voice
nor was he necessarily a musician but he
wanted to go into music he wanted to
create music company but he didn't have
the money to go all over the country
scouting out the best talent so what did
he do he looked around him and there
were teenagers all around him who were
the children of the great migration
children of people who had made this
great leap of faith into a northern city
forbidding northern city and one of them
was a 14 year old girl who had two
friends the 14 year old girl
the main one her parents her mother had
migrated from Alabama my father from
West Virginia they never would have met
had there been no great migration she
wouldn't even have existed had there
been no great migration she had two
friends who Mary Wilson and Florence
Ballard who both were also children of
the great migration their parents had
come from the south the Maine when I'm
mentioning is Diana Ross we simply would
not even know her name had there been a
great migration because first she
wouldn't have existed and Barry Gordy
wouldn't have been been able to meet
someone it didn't
so we wouldn't even know her name and of
course that he he found them against her
parents wishes they did not want her to
go into music but she did anyway and
there were born The Supremes
he also heard about it of course that
the temptations and all those other
groups all had roots in the south a tall
we're all part of this ascent the same
wave of people so an entire you know an
entire art form you might say or subset
of music was created as a result of this
great migration but berry gordy also
heard about this very large family in
Gary Indiana very large but there were
nine or ten kids nine or ten kids and
there were five boys in this large
family who were known for going around
to the different talent shows and
apparently winning all these talent
shows talent contests and the of the
five boys it was the youngest who seemed
to be the most talented some even the
father would have admitted and he was a
frontman at eight four for this group
and Barry Gordy discovered them of
course I'm talking about the Jackson
five who we would not even know the
names of because they wouldn't they too
would not have existed their mother
migrated from Alabama father from
Arkansas they meet outside of Chicago
moved to Gary Indiana have a lot of kids
who have amazing talent and therefore an
entire legendary family comes into being
that we would never even have known
about those are just a few of the
examples of popular music that just
simply wouldn't have existed had there
been no great migration there's so many
other people who are part of that as
well
but when it comes to jazz for example
and we'll give you two more examples of
things that would not have existed had
there been no great migration when it
comes to jazz the three pillars of jazz
again simply would we would not even
know their names Miles Davis for example
we wouldn't know his name
Miles Davis has his parents migrated
from Arkansas
Illinois where he had the opportunity to
the luxury really of being able to
practice to learn music to practice
music but she would never have had in
the cotton country of Arkansas now he'd
come from a fairly well situated family
but even then he would not have had the
opportunity to go to better schools
would have allowed him the option of
being able to take music in the way that
he ultimately was Thelonious Monk
because parents migrated from from North
Carolina to Harlem when he was five
years old where he too got the luxury of
being able to practice the piano to
learn music in a way that he never would
have had the opportunity to do had his
parents stayed in the tobacco country of
North Carolina and John Coltrane John
Coltrane migrated at the ripe old age of
seventeen which is kind of old beginning
a musical career in today's world he
left at age 17 from North Carolina to
Philadelphia and it was in Philadelphia
that he got his first alto sax he did
not touch an alto sax until he got to
Philadelphia his mother gave him one it
was a used one and then he went to the
Ornstein School of Music in Philadelphia
and he apparently played and played and
played on his off hours he was working
in a factory and I would submit to this
day that the people in his apartment
building would would deny this to this
day that they did what they did but they
actually complained to the landlord and
said there's this man in 12 C was
playing at all hours of the night and
you must make him stop because we can't
sleep little they know they were saying
that there's you know John Coltrane is
playing it we don't want to hear him
they would deny that I'm sure but where
where would where would jazz be where
would usik be where would culture be not
just American culture but culture in
this in the world because John Coltrane
is as popular in Tokyo in Paris as he is
here in the United States where we're
culture be had John Coltrane not gotten
on a train
and got into Philadelphia and gotten
ahold of an alto sax it's unfathomable
what that would have meant to music and
to our culture the culture as we know it
and that's just one example but I want
to leave you with one of the the most to
me stunning examples and I've so
grateful to have been able to actually
meet him Bill Russell Bill Russell the
NBA great it's frightening to think that
we might even might not even know his
name bill Russell's parents were living
in Monroe Louisiana which is a place
that I had to go back to for the book
which is the reason why is even in the
book because Monroe Louisiana figures
prominently in the book one of my three
protagonists was from Monroe and his
parents were having a very hard time of
it in the late 1930s and early 1940s at
one point his father went to a gas
station to get gas and he was having a
difficult time getting served and the
reason was because the southern protocol
required that all white patrons had to
be served before any black person could
be served no matter when the white
person showed up so if white patrons
kept coming up that meant he was going
to have to wait and wait and wait until
plate basically the place was empty or
the only person left to be served was
another black person in which case he
would then move to the front of the line
because he'd been there first well he
waited and he waited and white patrons
kept coming and he decided he was
running out of time and it needed to go
and he would just get gas another time
as he was backing out of the gas station
the proprietor set down the hose from
which he was using which he was using to
to service one of the white patrons and
he went over to bill Russell's father he
put a gun to his head and he said you'll
leave when I say you can leave and don't
ever do that again
bill Russell's mother at around the same
time was walking down in downtown Monroe
when a police officer stopped her she
was wearing her church clothes she had
saved up a long time to get this outfit
the police officer did not appreciate
what she had on because he thought that
it was
not in her not fit for someone of her
caste and he said he said go home right
now
take that off don't ever let me see that
see that on you again what you have on
is not fit for a colored woman only a
white woman should be in what you have
on if I see that in you on you again I
will arrest you this is your last
warning
Bill Russell was about eight or nine
years old at the time and he went came
home from school and he saw his mother
at the kitchen table and tears over the
streets that they were in because this
was a world but there was closing in on
them and there were no options there
were reminders from the moment they woke
up to the time they went to sleep that
they were in a different caste and that
there was no way out and that that it in
fact danger attended any potential
breach of that caste system so they set
out on a course for California they
decided that they would go to California
they caught the train first to st. Louis
in the state and the segregated train
and then when they got the st. Louis
which was a border city as is Washington
DC and and El Paso and Texas they in the
border city they could switch over to an
integrated train and it was called the
American Eagle and he remembered it to
this day Bill Russell with a little boy
and they set out on a course for Oakland
where he was able to go to integrate at
schools he said that we were like
immigrants we had to learn the language
that people spoke differently they ate
different kind of food which is exactly
what I experienced growing up too in a
way that the that we had to learn the
ways of this new place that we were in
and I felt like an immigrant he had the
opportunity to go to college in an
integrated school which he would never
been able to do in Louisiana because the
state schools even though African
Americans were contributing to the funds
because they were paying taxes they
could not go to the integrated state
schools actually they weren't integrated
they were white the white schools in
there
and there are respective states and so
he would not have had the opportunity to
go to the state school in Louisiana or
any white school in Louisiana but in
California in this new world he was able
to go to the University of San Francisco
and the University of San Francisco
happen to be an NCAA school he was very
tall as we all know and it turned out
that he was not just tall but he was
quite skilled and he led his team the
Dons to two n-c-double-a championships
which of course he never would even have
been able to go to an NC double-a school
had he been had his family stayed in
Louisiana it was because he was at that
school and had led that school to two
NCAA championships that he came to thee
to the attention of the Boston Celtics
he was hired onto the baltic boston
celtics and it was there that he led
boston to 11 of 13 championships NBA
championships and is considered even to
this day one of the greatest men ever to
played the game one of the greatest
defensive players ever and people who
follow the game for people who follow
the game it's almost unimaginable what
professional basketball would be had
there been no Bill Russell and yet we
might not even know his name had his
parents not migrated because he would
not have had the opportunity to even get
to the NBA to come to the attention of
the NBA he would very likely be working
in a sawmill and no one would know his
name that is the impact that this
migration had multiplied times six
million people and all of their children
and their children's children to the
point that I am even standing before you
today I wouldn't even be here where
they're not a great migration I want to
end this my discussion with I haven't
had a chance to talk much about the
three people the three people are item
an item a Gladney who migrated from
Luisi from Mississippi to Chicago in
1937 she had been a sharecroppers wife
who was terrible at picking cotton
and they ended up having to leave
because a cousin was beaten to women
within an inch of his life over a theft
that he did not commit afterward there
were no apologies it just was one of
those things that would happen in 1937
in Mississippi and after that her her
husband decided he said to her after he
saw what had happened to his cousin this
is the last crop were making and they
set out on a course for the north the
second person was a man who had been a
college student but the money ran out
and there was no opportunity for him to
go to this to the school near his family
which would have made it possible for
him to go to school he couldn't go he
could no longer afford board really and
so he and he couldn't go to the white
school and in his region so he had to
return to the work of the region of
Florida where he was which was citrus
picking and ultimately he had to flee
for his life to Harlem because he had
been agitating for better wages and work
conditions for the people were picking
fruit the work was very dangerous and a
crime and a 40-foot trees the pay was
was reflected the what what little value
the growers ascribed to the work which
was meaning that they paid them ten or
twelve cents for a box of fruit which
might take them over several several
most of the day to pick and so under
great peril and so he was trying to
agitate for better wages and as a result
of that he had he had to flee for his
life because unions were not welcome at
that time and particularly not from
African Americans who would have the
gall to stand up to the growers in the
way that George Starling was doing that
so he fled from from Florida to Harlem
in 1945 and then the last person was
Robert Joseph Pershing Foster who was a
physician a surgeon in the US Army and
he had performed Abele in the army and
and had been permitted to to practice
medicine but when he got out of the army
after the Korean conflict it turned out
that he could not practice surgery in
his/her own home
of Monroe Louisiana the same town that
bill Russell's family had come from and
so he decided that he was going to set
out for for California and that meant a
perilous journey of driving through the
night multiple nights without sleep
because he could not find a place to
rest no place would allow him to would
give him a went would rent him a room
and he had to go through the hairpin
curves and the mountains in the desert
of Arizona New Mexico and into
California he had not anticipated that
he after he would have to drive that far
without rest and it was it was not only
perilous but it was dispiriting to him
because he realized that perhaps they
made him wonder what was this place he
was going to and would it in fact be any
better not something that probably
weighs on the mind of anyone who ever
leaves one place for another because
there are no guarantees what is it that
you're doing and you often think about
what you this person had to go through
just to make the decision and once you
made the decision you'd like to believe
you made the right decision
and he was not certain as it did that
but I want to read to you this passage
about him about where when I first met
him this was the this was the day that I
first met Robert Joseph Pershing Foster
a character unto himself Los Angeles
1996 the panel door rises a story high
and would be fit a museum or government
office but is actually the front door of
a Spanish Revival south of Wilshire the
door opens and there stands a one-time
bourbon swilling army captain and deft
handed surgeon who now in his later
years as a regular at the blackjack
tables and the trifectas at Santa Anita
but he is at the heart of it all and
perhaps most important a long-standing
still bitter and somewhat obsessive
expatriate from the 20th century south
the heartbreak Jim Crowe Landy chose to
reject the for could reject him again
he's a Californian now this Robert
Joseph Pershing Foster he is the color
of strong coffee and has ways in his
hair which he lets grow as untamed
design Stein's but then brushes back
like the boys in the band he's wearing a
white cotton Island shirt loose slacks
and sandals the uniform of the
well-to-do LA pensioner he has the build
and bearing
Sammy Davis jr. and not a little of the
showmanship and delightful delightful
superficiality that seemed to grow on
people in certain circles of LA whenever
I read that in LA I think to myself I
needed to edit that out I meant to edit
out the superficiality part but then you
know when I've read it they just say yep
that's us we're superficial they loved
it he walked straight back and flutes we
footed into the 4ea past the curve fo
Gone with the Wind staircase in the East
Asian pottery he just restored the
living room an imposing space that
dwarfs him in its volume fairly frozen
in the seafoam carpet and hot pink tulip
chairs out of a sure buddy Doris Day
movie from the 50s the whole effect is a
starched and formal as a tuxedos II used
to wear to the parties he threw for
himself back when Alice his wife was
alive and the money was raining down
like confetti
he seems accustomed to people fawning
over the place and with the prim air of
leading men of his favorite movies from
back in the 40s insists on serving his
guests a slice of lemon pound cake and
vanilla ice cream on Rosenthal China
whether they would like to have it or
not he is a physician or was for most of
his adult life and by most accounts a
very good one and is prone to
pontificate like a man of his years and
accomplishments but he's just as likely
to interrupt himself and check the time
to see if he can still make the one
o'clock at the Hollywood Park Racetrack
his photo albums are filled with an
unlikely assortment of bookies and blues
singers and dentists and fraternity men
and surgeons and society people whose
approval he craved even though he knew
they were too pretentious to matter
really he doesn't say it because it
would be gauche and hardly worth
mentioning from his point of view but
there happened to be a lot of little
Roberts around town due to the fact that
over the years he delivered a number of
baby boys his mother's were so grateful
for his firm hand and calming
reassurances at the precise moment of
truth that they named their sons not
after their husbands but after the
doctor who delivered their babies before
he begins the story he tells you it's a
long one and you can't get it all he's
lived too many lives done too much known
too many people
written so high and so low that there's
no point in fooling us
into thinking you can capture the whole
of it you could try of course and he
agrees to give as much as he can I love
to talk he says a smile forming on his
still chiseled face as he sits upright
in his tulip chair and I am my favorite
subject thank you so much I'm so happy
to take your question